thank you red hat for sponsoring this
video have you ever wondered how large
companies handle the cloud operations or
how businesses scale their online
services to meet demand in this video
we're going to dive into a very
important Concept in the IT world known
as Cloud automation this is the secret
behind the streamlined efficient Cloud
infrastructures you see powering today's
digital world so whether you're a job
Seeker or someone already working in
Tech keep watching because this is a
valuable skill set that could
potentially make a big difference in
your career let's get into it Cloud
automation to put it simply is the use
of Technologies and tools to automate
the management of workloads in the cloud
this process involves automating the
setup scaling and maintenance of cloud
resources now why is it so important
imagine a world without cloud automation
every time you need more Cloud servers
to handle the increased customer demand
you'll have to manually log in and
configure each one not to mention if
there's ever a spike in traffic scaling
your systems fast enough would be nearly
impossible Cloud automation can address
these issues and so much more let's say
I'm setting up an e-commerce store where
I'm planning on selling shoes if I I
consider implementing Cloud automation
from day one here are some of the
benefits it can bring the business
firstly there will be a reduction in the
time and effort spent on routine Cloud
management tasks rather than getting
bogged down on day-to-day operations it
would allow more time to focus on
strategic goals in my case growing the
shoe business and improving customer
satisfaction another benefit is error
minimalization automation will help me
reduce the likelihood of human error for
example automated systems can allow me
to more easily manage inventory levels
process orders and display a accurate
information this means there will be
fewer mistakes in orders with up-to-date
inventory and pricing for customers the
third Advantage is enhanced scalability
and adaptability with Cloud automation
the infrastructure on my shoe store can
effortlessly scale up and down to match
demand whether it's a sudden spike in
traffic during a sale or a steady
increase over time the system can adapt
seamlessly this will result in a smooth
shopping experience for my customers
regardless of how many people are on the
website at the same time okay but Cloud
automation isn't just helpful for e
Commerce store owners it's a powerful
tool for any organization that uses the
cloud companies are moving beyond the
traditional ways of handling their
processes they're stepping into a future
where more and more of their Cloud
operations are getting streamlined this
shift allows companies to respond
quickly to Market changes and their
customer needs the global Cloud
automation Market is about to experience
substantial growth over the next few
years organizations need to optimize
their operations in order to stay ahead
and so Cloud automation will be a way to
help them save money whilst increasing
efficiency and and that's exactly why I
would highly recommend learning about
Cloud automation whether you're a
developer it manager or someone running
your own company chances are you'll
start to see the impact of Automation in
your work environment by learning about
the different automation tools out there
you'll be able to up school in your Tech
Career or drive your business forward
now let me introduce you to a major
player in the cloud automation space the
red hat anible automation platform this
is an Enterprise solution that
transforms how Cloud operations are
managed at scale with anible it managers
can set automation guidelines whilst
giving developers the freedom to
innovate it pretty much streamlines the
process of sharing reviewing and
controlling automation practices within
an organization without limiting
flexibility an's capabilities go beyond
just deployment and retirement of cloud
resources it integrates with Azure
resource manager terraform and AWS cloud
formation enhancing your existing Cloud
operations I actually stopped by the red
hat kiosk at AWS reer a few weeks ago
where I listened to a presentation about
the anible platform and it was really to
see some of the use cases in action you
can use the anable automation platform
across a wide range of cloud automation
scenarios and transform complex tasks
into streamlined processes some examples
include multicloud management so whether
you're working with AWS Azure or Google
Cloud anible provides a unified way to
automate tasks across these environments
another one is cicd pipeline automation
where anible integrates cicd pipelines
helping automate the deployment of
applications and infrastructure updates
it also automates security policies and
compliance checks ensuring that your
Cloud environments adhere to the
necessary regulations and best practices
okay now you might be asking how do I
get started with anible and Cloud
automation well Red Hats free
interactive labs are a great starting
point these Hands-On demos are perfect
for beginners and will give you a feel
of an's power in managing hybrid Cloud
environments you can see here that
there's Labs like getting started with
anible Navigator getting started with
automation controller and writing your
very first Playbook these tutorials only
take about 30 to 60 Minutes to complete
and here's an example of what one of the
labs look like on the left you have your
editor or environment and on the right
you have stepbystep instructions these
labs are a fun and interactive way to
get familiar with Cloud Automation and
they're also really helpful for seeing
how anible can be applied to real world
scenarios if you're interested in trying
it out for yourself I've added a link in
the description below to the labs
they're completely free and an excellent
way to start experimenting for those who
prefer reading you can also check out
this ebook for an easy to understand
guide on cloud automation all right so
this brings us to the end of the video
please give it a like if you found it
helpful and don't forget to check out
the cloud automation resources in the
description
below